here's a pretty amazing story brittany
aldean is the wife of country music star
jason aldean recently she uploaded a
video to instagram it showed her putting
on makeup it's on your screen right now
and then she added this caption to the
footage and we're quoting i'd really
like to thank my parents for not
changing my gender when i went through
my tomboy phase i love this girly life
and then her husband responded with this
captioning wrote i'm glad they didn't
too because you and i wouldn't have
worked out that was it
now no sane society would have a problem
with or even notice words like that but
in 2022 this is a thought crime you're
required to believe that minors should
be castrated by their parents so there
was massive backlash online a country
music ceremony called cassidy pope
accused al dean of wronging lgbtq plus
people for writing that
and then a lunatic called marin morris
some kind of fake country music singer
went all the way she wrote this it's so
easy to be like not a scumbag human
cellular's clip-ins in zipit
insurrection barbie
and then of course brittany aldean was
attacked
up and down the american media for
telling a transphobic joke which they
never quoted at all you had no idea what
she said we just showed you what she
said
they really attacked her to her great
credit she's not backing down in fact
she's got a new clothing line out called
don't tread on kids and we are honored
to have brittany aldean join us tonight
freddie thanks so much for coming on the
more i read about this the more i was i
was legitimately shocked by the
dishonesty of the response but the
viciousness
especially from the this that second
woman awful were you surprised by this
yes i was extremely surprised i you know
in saying my response i never thought
that there was anything wrong with it um
i think i'm advocating for children i
think that children should not be
allowed to make these life-changing
decisions at such a young age they are
not mature enough
they are just they should have parents
that love them and advocate for them
regardless
we have ages on everything right we have
it for cigarettes we have it for driving
we have it for military voting
yet for some reason people or think that
we can let a child choose their gender
so young it's very baffling to me well
especially when
that process is irreparable i mean you
wind up castrating children removing
their sex organs making them sterile for
life i mean these are huge consequences
huge consequences and i think when
you're older if you choose to make those
decisions by all means but children are
too young not mature enough to make
those decisions and they're
life-changing like you said they may not
be able to have children one day there's
so many consequences to doing that at
such a young age and us as parents us as
a society regardless of political status
should be able to sit back speak our
minds about it and fight for these
children
there's been a huge effort by corporate
america you've seen in the nfl and
you've seen it in country music to
control
the entertainment forums that middle
class america likes and country music is
of course one of the biggest please make
us feel better and tell us that you know
people in nashville who've called you
personally to say they're on your side
so much support so much support
especially people that have children
there's definitely you have the other
the side of that too and that's fine
people are entitled to their opinions
but that's just it we as conservatives
have a very hard time having an opinion
especially in society today in the media
in relationships in the workplace and
it's very very sad but a lot of support
within nashville and just friends and
family for sure they didn't even ask
your opinion they immediately and that
that that second country music person
who i hope leaves country music
immediately for the viciousness yes of
her attack she just attacked you
personally it's just it's beyond belief
yes yes and i've never had a
conversation with either of these people
this is simply based on opinion and
political status
that's the worst we appreciate your
bravery brittany aldean thank you so
much for coming on tonight thank you
tucker
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight